y esto de aquí es un ejercicio de la
sección de ejercicios de descripción de
subgrupos de espacio de muestreo vamos a
realizar un par de estos ejercicios ya
que es una buena práctica el pensar en
cómo describimos grupos y subgrupos
veamos el primer problema a mi isám ya
tienen un sombrero que contiene dos
cartas unas y un rey están jugando un
juego en el que sacan una carta al azar
de el sombrero cuatro veces volviendo la
metas a mí piensa que la probabilidad de
sacar dos ases exactamente en las cuatro
veces es igual a la probabilidad de no
veces sam ya no está de acuerdo
ella piensa que la probabilidad de no
sacar dos ases exactamente es mayor aquí
nos dice que el espacio muestral de
resultados posibles se muestra a
continuación a representa un as y que
representa un rey quien tiene razón a mí
osa mía aquí tenemos las opciones a mí
tiene razón o sam ya tiene razón aquí
está el espacio muestral de resultados
posibles todos los resultados dos
posibles que pueden tener en este juego
para sacar aces o reyes
bueno veamos cuántos resultados hay 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 16
posibles resultados y nos dicen que a mí
piensa que la probabilidad de sacar dos
ases exactamente veamos cuáles de estos
tenemos dos ases exactamente aquí hay
uno
aquí está el otro 23 aquí aquí hay otro
4 aquí no aquí no aquí sí 5 y aquí 6
resultados en los que hay dos haces
exactamente pero queremos que eran 16
los resultados así que tenemos 6 entre
16 veamos ahora la probabilidad de no
secar dos ases exactamente qué son todas
las opciones que no contamos al
principio aquí tenemos una dos tres está
no es así cuatro cinco seis están aquí 7
8 está no está tampoco 9 está así
también la cuento 10 estas otras 2 no
tengo 10 resultados de 16 resultados
posibles que corresponden a la
probabilidad de no sacar dos haces
exactamente entonces si comparamos la
probabilidad de sacar exactamente dos
aces queramos que era 6 de 16 esta vez
no sacar dos haces exactamente 10 de 16
es mayor esta probabilidad de 10 de 16
que la de sacar exactamente dos ases por
lo que la mía tiene razón vamos a
comprobar la respuesta
el siguiente problema nos dice
el espacio muestra el siguiente muestra
los resultados de los últimos ocho
partidos que jugó el equipo de fútbol
inglés manchester united durante su
campeonato de la temporada 2012/2013
ganaron los partidos en los que anotaron
más goles que sus oponentes perdieron
los partidos en los que anotaron menos y
empataron los partidos en los que
anotaron la misma cantidad si tomamos
los partidos 1 2 4 6 y 7 como subgrupo
del espacio muestral cuáles de las
proposiciones siguientes describen a
este subgrupo veamos cuáles son las
opciones y cuáles son los elementos de
nuestro subgrupo dice los partidos 1
vemos que aquí en este partido 1
manchester united tuvo un gol y el
oponente dos goles en el partido 2
manchester tuvo 2 goles y el oponente 0
en el partido 4 manchester tuvo 3 goles
y el oponente 0 goles
veamos los demás en el partido 6
manchester tuvo 0 el oponente 1 en el
partido 7
él tuvo dos y el oponente 1
veamos las opciones la primera el
subgrupo consta de todos los partidos en
los que no hubo en parte eso es correcto
empates solamente cuando los dos equipos
tienen la misma cantidad de goles pero
vemos aquí que hay un gol y el otro
metido dos goles en el otro partido
manchester metió dos goles el otro 0 en
el 4 metieron tres goles el lote equipo
0 en el 6 fueron 0 goles un gol en el 72
goles un gol por lo que aquí en ninguno
hay empate esta primera opción si se
cumple vemos los otros partidos que no
son de nuestro subgrupo y vemos que aquí
tenemos 2 goles a 2 goles aquí abajo un
gol a un gol y aquí abajo 5 goles a 5
goles así que esta primera opción si se
cumple la siguiente opción el subgrupo
consta de todos los partidos en los que
el oponente de manchester united no ganó
este no se cumple ya que tenemos
partidos en los que ganan manchester y
otros en los que gana el oponente como
vemos aquí en el partido uno ganó el
oponente también en el partido 6 ganó el
oponente así que esta no se cumple
veamos la tercera opción el subgrupo
consta de todos los partidos en los que
manchester united
o perdió esta si se cumple ya que en
estos partidos o ganó o perdió en este
por ejemplo perdió pero en el siguiente
ganó 2 a 0 en el que el siguiente ganó 3
a 0 en el sexto perdió y en el séptimo
ganó así que esto sí se cumple la última
opción en su grupo consta de todos los
partidos en los que manchester united no
ganó ya vimos que este no se cumple ya
que hay partidos en los que ha ganado y
otros en los que ha perdido así que sólo
tenemos dos opciones que aplica
vamos a ver nuestra respuesta veamos
comprobar la respuesta correcta hemos
terminado